Michael Kohn has made many statements to
the house as I understand it and the
Senate he put out a statement talking
about a project which was essentially I
guess more or less of an option that we
were looking at in Moscow everybody knew
about it it was written about in
newspapers there was a well-known
project it was during the early part of
16 and I guess even before that it
lasted a short period of time I didn't
do the project I decided not to do the
project so I didn't do it so we're not
talking about doing a project we're
talking about not doing a project
Michael Kohn what he's doing is he was
convicted I guess you'll have to put it
into legal terms but he was convicted
with a fairly long term sentence on
things totally unrelated to the Trump
Organization having to do with mortgages
and having to do with cheating the IRS
perhaps a lot of different things I
don't know exactly but he was convicted
of various things unrelated to us he was
given a fairly long jail sentence and
he's a weak person and by being weak
unlike other people that you watch he's
a weak person and what he's trying to do
is get a reduced sentence so he's lying
about a project that everybody knew
about I mean we were very open with it
we were thinking about building a
building I guess we had in a forum it
was an option I don't know what you'd
call it
we decided I decided ultimately not to
do it there would have been nothing
wrong if I did do it if I did do it
there would have been nothing wrong
that's was my business
so he's lying very simply to get a
reduced sentence okay III don't know
when I decided but somewhere during the
period of time I was never very enthused
somewhere during the period because I
was running for president my focus was
running for president but I when I run
for president that doesn't mean I'm not
allowed to do business I was doing a lot
of different things when I was running
after I won obviously I don't do
business one from January 20th but more
importantly which is a following year
but I ran a business in fact I often
joke about the fact that I was the only
person that campaigned and
simultaneously ran a business but that
was that was a project that we didn't do
I didn't do that was a project that
wasn't done for a lot of reasons number
one is that I was really not that I had
to do it but I was focused on running
for president I wanted that to be my
primary focus not running or building a
building well this was a deal that
didn't happen that was No Deal
I mean if you look this was an option I
guess I don't know if I want it I want
to be very specific so but to my way of
thinking it was an option that I decided
that to do
so we didn't sell if you look we really
didn't have shizmik so excuse me excuse
me this was an option in a forum but
here's very simple we had a position to
possibly do a deal to build a building
of some kind in Moscow I decided not to
do it the primary reason that could have
been other reasons but the primary
reason it was very simple I was focused
on running for president there would be
nothing wrong if I did do it I was
running my business while I was
campaigning there was a good chance that
I wouldn't have won in which case I
would have gotten back into the business
and why should I lose lots of
opportunities so here is the story go
back and look at the paper that Michael
Kohn wrote before he testified in the
house and/or Senate it talked about his
position what he's trying to do because
he's a weak person and not a very smart
person what he's trying to do is end and
it's very simple he's got himself a big
prison sentence and he's trying to get a
much lesser prison sentence by making up
the story now here's the thing even if
he was right it doesn't matter because I
was allowed to do whatever I wanted
during the campaign I was running my
business a lot of different things
during the campaign so very simply
Michael Kohn is lying and he's trying to
get a reduced sentence for things that
have nothing to do with me now let me go
a step further I think you should go
back to I think it was January it was
just reported very well by Catherine
Herridge is that horrific we put her on
Fox she talks about a letter that he
signed I don't even remember it and it
specifically talks about this deal this
deal was a very public deal everybody
knows about this deal I wasn't trying to
hide anything okay